what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of Spider-Man
news and a bunch of different areas
we're talking the MCU we're talking the
Sony spider-verse and also the animated
spider-verse that is the across the
Spider-Man universe that people don't
really know at this point in time if
it's going to cross over into the
live-action Sony spider-verse because it
looks like it is in fact going to be
crossing over into the MCU we also have
some news about Spider Woman and it
looks like there is going to be more
than one Spider Woman coming to the Sony
spider-verse and in the midst of all of
this we are still wondering how exactly
the Sony Spider-Man universe and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are going to
connect because this has been hinted at
by a Sony director now of course
Spider-Man know a home kind of connected
the two different universes however Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man are not a part of Sony's new
spiderverse at least not yet but of
course we'll further talk about that in
this video now some Sony does apparently
seem to be building up a big universe
for Spider-Man and all of the Spider-Man
characters leading up to a big event
much like Marvel Studios does with the
Avengers films you have your individual
movies about individual characters and
then you build it up to where all of
those characters come together for a
huge event and it's looking like this
huge event is going to be a huge
spider-verse Collision for Sony with a
bunch of different Spider-Man variants
and characters but an interesting rumor
that has come out today makes us Wonder
just who exactly is going to be involved
we've recently heard from Insider Jeff
Snyder that he's heard a rumor that Tom
Holland Spider-Man is going to appear in
across the spider-verse the animated
movie furthermore Daniel rpk on his
patreon account states that across the
spider verse is going to reference the
events that took place in Spider-Man no
way home which is very interesting
because if this does indeed actually
happen it would make us assume that the
animated spider-verse that Sony has
right now with into the spider-verse and
across the spider person than beyond the
spider-verse it would make us assume
that these animated movies are actually
kind of Canon to their live-action
movies and not only that but also part
of the MCU or at least one movie and one
character could be Canon to the
spider-verse as well however according
to Daniel rpk into the spider-verse is
actually going to reference Doctor
Strange according to Daniel rpk the
characters in across the spider-verse
will reference that something bad
happened to the Multiverse due to a
certain event and the mess that doctor
strange and the nerdy kid caused the
nerdy kid obviously being Tom Holland
Spider-Man but this is big because this
is them referencing a non-spiderman
character yes of course he was in the
Spider-Man film so that kind of makes it
okay but Doctor Strange is an MCU
character and they are referencing an
MCU character here so this is huge news
this means that the Sony spider-verse
can now essentially reference the MCU
and we could potentially start to see
some pretty decent crossovers here which
is honestly something that we are kind
of really hoping for at least to a
certain extent many people would love
Tom Hardy's Venom to enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for real not just in
and out in two post credit scenes but
some people might not like morbius in
the MCU however I think most people do
want Tom Holland Spider-Man to be a part
of the Sony spider-verse as well as the
MCU of course but speak speaking about
Venom and the Venom post credit scenes
along with the Spider-Man no way home
post credit scene one thing that the
director of the Venom movie said Andy
Circus was very very interesting and it
makes us wonder what exactly the plan is
with the Sony Spider-Man verse and the
MCU when it came down to explaining the
post-credit scenes for Venom 2 and
Spider-Man no way home why Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock and Venom went to the MCU
and then came back this is what he had
to say about it in an interview with
comicbook.com he stated we wanted to
leave the audience knowing that these
universes are going to somehow Collide
and we wanted to do it in such a way
that it still leaves so much open tying
them together means that there's still
potential for they're literally the
portal is not being crossed fully it's
opening up more questions I suppose I
mean that was the intention of it to
tease it's a tease and the fullest sense
of the word so that's what Andy Circus
had to say about the Venom 2
post-credits scene seemingly making and
very clear that the two universes are
going to collide now as far as how they
are going to collide I'm assuming it is
just going to be Spider-Man characters
once the Fantastic Four debut I'm not
expecting Reed Richards to pop up in the
Sony Spider-Man universe anywhere but
what I think this does mean is that our
Spider-Man Tom Holland and any other
Spider-Man that may come along like
Miles Morales and any other characters
in those movies can cross over into the
Sony spider-verse and then hopefully
characters like Venom or Carnage or
anybody else could eventually cross over
into the MCU we do know that there is
going to be a Venom symbiote in one of
the upcoming Spider-Man movies and who
knows maybe it could actually be Tom
Hardy's Venom or at least a variant of
him however the universe is colliding is
more along the lines of the Spider-Man
characters from the MCU are going to be
going to the Sony spider-verse and we've
gotten some rumors that the big
crossover event could be spider get him
essentially where you have 20 to 30
different Spider-Man variants appearing
in one universe all coming together to
fight a giant threat and like I
mentioned Apparently one of the
Spider-Man characters that we are going
to be getting is Spider Woman but two
different versions of the character
according to a new report Sydney Sweeney
is going to be playing Spider-Woman in
Madame web but she is going to be
playing Julia Carpenter's Spider-Woman
on the hot mic podcast Insider Jeff
Snyder said that he has been told that
Sydney sweetie is going to be playing
Spider-Woman in Madam Webb however it is
going to be Julia Carpenter not Jessica
Drew and it is important to clarify this
because Olivia Wilde still has a project
coming up that is going to be a Spider
Woman project that is going to
apparently be a part of the Sony
spider-verse and that project has been
heavily rumored to be about Jessica
Drew's Spider-Woman so those are going
to be two completely different versions
of Spider-Woman however it does like
both of them will come together in the
spider-verse and the Madame Web movie
should be the start of the Multiverse
for Sony as we know it in the comment
Madam Webb is basically a cosmic entity
and she can travel the Multiverse so
hopefully that is something that we see
start to happen in this Madam web film
and of course we have heard plenty of
rumors for a long time now actually
since Spider-Man no way home came out
stating that Sony wasn't done with Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man yet and they wanted them to
stick around for other projects well
perhaps we could see one of them or
maybe even both of them show up in the
Madame web film if spider gedden truly
is the goal for Sony to have their huge
Avengers in-game style event but just
with Spider-Man and variations of
Spider-Man then it would make sense that
Tom Holland's Spider-Man would show up
in that film along with Toby Maguire
Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man and if this report from
Daniel rpk ends up being true and he
does have a good track record that means
that into the spider-verse is going to
be Canon to the live-action spider verse
as well and they are already referencing
the event that happened in no way home
so this makes Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
and Toby Maguire Spider-Man Canon to the
live-action spider verse as well opening
it up for them to return and fingers
crossed that they do because I know we
would love to see those three Spider-Man
back together again along with a lot of
other different Spider-Man characters if
spider gedden actually happens but let
us know what you think about all of this
news about Spider-Man and the different
characters of Spider-Man in the comments
down below and please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
Spider-Man news both in the Sony
spider-verse and in the MCU you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof